um
talk about you know obviously you guys
got the grammy nomination for revenge of
the dreamers um three which was uh
you know i i told eve this like you know
the fact that he was able to
craft such a um
amazing amazingly sequenced body of work
because he you know was was like letting
me know about kind of um
how many songs he had to choose from and
then just the way they
they flowed and it was like it felt like
i know and i know
all the sessions were scattered but it
really felt like everybody was kicking
it in the studio together
and y'all made like a cohesive body of
work um
share with me um some of your favorite
moments about those sessions because
you know we hear about how legendary
they were everybody was getting flown
out
like you know i just always think back
to how special of a moment that was to
have the baby on that record with cole
like
you know what i mean so yeah yeah talk
talk about those sessions for um revenge
of the dreamers three and like some some
memories you have from them
i mean it really was just the
camaraderie you know i'm saying like
the creativity and the camaraderie all
in one space from like
people all across the industry people
who you just you know i'm saying you
ain't never met them but you see them
shining and stuff and it's like
when y'all get into the same place it's
just love i'm saying like it ain't
really like
how many followers you got oh you ain't
got that man you can't be on this song
type of energy you know what i'm saying
so like
that that we let that block the
creativity and the energy that was going
through the room and through the
building so
to me that's like my favorite aspect of
it yeah it was cool when some legends
pulled
up too like ross pulled up they kind of
put like some people that wasn't even on
the project they were just legendary
people that was in atlanta at the time
and they came through
like to be a part of city i feel like
the greater part of
the bucks roster pull it up like the
milwaukee bucks they was in town giannis
was there
yeah yeah so giannis pulled up for the
oh you know who pulled up surprised the
hell out of me
uh what's brother name used to play for
miami
and he's playing from canada uh miami
from canada
i don't know i can't think of his name
right now but he used to play back for
miami he's super tall bro he he
he's part of lebron's championship down
there
center bro let's bro name bro i'm
tripping right now because i'm high
canadian player used to be uh you
sitting right next to me bro
uh pull up the miami heat roster oh he
talked about um
20 2013 miami heat restaurant he talked
about chris bye
bye okay yeah i didn't want to say not
from canada
yeah i was about to say he played in
toronto
i said that wrong chris bosh was there
in the room he in the small room the
smallest of the studio rooms two two two
he was in there
it's already like it's crowded when one
[ __ ] walk in there it's probably like
smaller than this it's probably like
five six [ __ ] in there and he's a he's
like seven feet tall seven feet tall
he's sitting in the corner
folded up with his laptop in his lap
making beats and i'm like
chris bosh was making beats bruh i go in
there and i'm like
i seen him at first but he in the corner
so tucked up like like behind some like
furniture i'm like
i when
creativity in the room you know what's
crazy is uh
well first of all how was how was chris
bosh's beats
i felt like it was pretty important i
feel like i feel like i feel like i was
pleasantly surprised like i feel like i
gave him one of these like
yeah fire yeah and then giannis being
there i didn't even know like giannis
was like hip-hop
he's from greece so i don't know you
know like the whole team pulled it up
you know playing pool with george hill
and [ __ ]
george hill yeah pool play at night i'm
so many [ __ ] in the league just
respect cole of course
and plus like he could low key make an
nba roster yeah
i hear like he's like he'd be hooping
like he's he's always training with that
what's the uh the dude the the the
trainer in new york could be training
all the nba players
he'd be running it and then his first
couple of projects was like basketball
yeah they were all bastard he had a
basketball on the internet on each other
yeah he's in london
so like that's definitely all part of
the vibe no 100
yeah did dennis smith junior pull up i
know he's he's real close with cold he
pulled up to them
he's pulled up to the house a bunch of
times like he's been watching black
mirror with him
black man